陆以七最近因为观察这个期权结构对最近行情引发的思考
大概我就写在这里
最近的行情是什么呢
我把它总结为GAP&TROP就是电子盘巨大缺口
然后它不像以前就是GAP&FIL那种结构
它每盘不会去填补反而在某一个价位附近不停的TROP
我觉得为什么呢
主要是因为最近的行情都是新闻在驱动
战争的不确定性
大家都不知道仗什么时候打完
这个时候非常像什么
你可以去
你可以等我说完这些去回看一下就是20年的口罩的时期和20年
暴力加薪的时期
这个原因它会导致这个期权结构
尤其是VIX和BELP的结构
第一是它的期权结构
期限结构深度的贴水
就是静月和远一个深度贴水
第二是什么
SKL曲线它深度的偏袭
如果我画出来
画画在哪里
正常来说
由于时间的不确定性
对吧
因为你不知道后面会发生什么样的事情
所以说对于VIX它的期权
它一般的期限结构是这样子
但是最近发生的深度贴水
导致它的期限结构变成了这样
然后BELP的SKL曲线
正常来说
大概就是这样
它是像一个微笑曲线
但最近是什么样子
深度偏袭
我不会在这里解释任何这种基础的问题
就是能看懂的话就看
看不懂就算了
我只是单纯把我自己的想法录下来
这并不是一个教学
这并不是一个教学视频
只是我的一个记录视频
这个的它的来由在哪里呢
在这里
你可以去看看BADCHART
你看这是VIX它的进阅
比如我们看3月25号
你去看它的VI
然后IV
然后看它的这些比较虚直期权的
未平仓的数量
然后再去看看它远跃的
比如说这是4月15号的
可以看到它的IV
它处在一个贴水的状态
然后如果你去看标普
这个是3月20号
去看它的那些虚直期权以及它的IV
还有它的仓位
这个是4月的
然后再叠加一个什么呢
就是VIX它是标普未来30日的波动型
然后还有一个VIX
就是它对于VIX这个指数的波动型
现在的VIX是多少呢
是125
这个什么概念
这个时候要打开
我们可以先观察一下
它的正常的区间在哪里呢
在日本央行加息之前
我看什么时候
大概是24年的8月
24年8月之前
它的一个正常区间
应该是在80到100
然后变化是从什么时候发生的
首先是8月央行加息
央行加息有大量套保的资金流出
然后之后又叠加了一个
好像是什么数据
我忘了CPI还是什么
就业率反正大幅不及预期
然后再加上日金好像8月5号吧
还是8月几号
直接直接跌停
然后从那之后VIX的区间
再叠加一个24年当时
后面我看大概11月吧
11月穿着要准备上台
从那之后
这个区间就从80到100变成了
90到110
整整上升了大概10个级点
甚至是90到120
你可以看到这里明显的
明显的区别
就是大家对于波动率的波动率
这个预期在它的风值和风股
在放大
125是个什么概念
处于一个极高位
这会导致什么
这会导致
每天都会因为这种
战争行情的不确定性
去买入非常高昂的保险
因为你每天都要买入大量的
大量的
架外的VIX的CALL
因为你怕它战争什么时候不结束
或者是突然打个导弹什么的
对吧
然后VIX疯狂的标准
你需要去买虚直的CALL
然后你还要干嘛呢
你还要去
你还要去去去去去去
去买大量的就是远越到期的
标普的虚直的POOT
因为你不能
许多大资金
它不能够去堵弹边
它必须要去买保险
万一如果说标普
真的什么
打仗又重 战火重燃了
对吧
然后穿着
邪恶穿着
要统一世界来干嘛的
它必须要有虚直POOT
它去兜住它的底
因为它手上持有大量的
现货股票
它需要去做一个对冲的保护
但是由于这个高
VIX
它会导致一个什么现象呢
就是这一部分的成本极高
因为IV非常的高
你像坐式商
他会说可以
我可以替你兜这个底
对吧
因为你要撮合交易
你坐式商愿意去接你的另单
但是因为这个IV极高
所以你需要付出
非常非常高昂的成本
这个就导致了一个什么现象
导致了
现在对于VIX它的期权
大量的期权是
在做一个反向的日理价差
就是说
我去买这个
我去买进月的CALL
但是卖出远月的POOT
还有就是对角价差
去读这个回归
就去读
往后往后
肉一个月之后VIX价格
因为它不会永远在高位
对吧
你可以看到这个
你可以看到
你看到它永远会在一个峰值
然后下来会
正常都会在一个区间
一个更窄的区间里波动
还有就是一部分的垂直价差
这个我实在是不知道用汉语
去怎么翻译
感觉怎么翻译都很奇怪
就是CREATED SPRIDE
就是去执行一个收租的策略
因为这个权力金非常高
所以我每天就去MAC
然后去收租
还有就是Diabit Spread
我去堵一个方向
去堵它
继续往上
这个其实应该放在
放在这里
这一部分应该放在这里
就是它垂直价差
它既可以在VIX
去卖高埃威的PUT
然后它再去买入一个
更深虚极的PUT
去兜底做一个垂直价差
要么就是在标普里面
对吧
如果你想要去堵它的方向
但是你不可能去
如果你觉得价格
因为在高VIX的趋势下
你觉得标普会低
但是你不可能去裸PUT
这个时候你会干嘛呢
你会去买
就是更远越到期
比如说4月到期的PUT
然后你的保险是什么呢
你去卖一张
更深虚极的PUT
这个时候如果价格跌下去
你卖的更深虚极的PUT
因为它的埃威
它就可以抵消掉你买
你买更高价格PUT的
成本
这个时候不管
你就去掉了埃威的风险
因为不管埃威涨还是跌
你的单子
不会受到波动率的影响
你可以纯粹去
转这个方向的利润
然后到这里
由于这些
由于
还有一个就是日内铁音
这个太变态了
这个
你可以去看看
你就看一看
最近
这个
这个标普
日内铁音
有多变态
就是当然这个
这种ETA这长和每盘
每盘横
就是该盘的超
这个原因我会在后面再
再去说出我的看法
但是你可以去看看
就是这些
从大概从
2月2月什么时候开始
日内铁音策略
它的胜率有多高
你可以去自己
自己去复判一下
反正非常的夸张
他就在赌
他就在赌价格
价格虽然会大幅的跳空
但是价格不会激传普多
就是
永远会有人在那里兜底
他永远在收足
在那个区间内
这个
这个我可以挪一个非常经典的一天
我可以挪到
3月16号这一天
你可以看看
你可以看这一天
从开盘开始
这个时候
是干嘛呢
就是货利盘
前一天的货利盘
和那个因为跳空导致的
平仓盘
他在对红
疯狂对红中
然后这个时候价格在涨对不对
然后到了10点这个时候开始
各种那个价差和铁音策略就开始入场
你可以看到这上面下面
然后对通压力疯狂的下行对吧
但是价格价格下不去
价格下不去
铁音疯狂铁音无限铁音
无限赚钱
无限音潮
最后收敛这一部分
然后结束
所以说由于以上的种种
这些策略和VVX
他到了125
以及这种战争行情的影响
他就会导致什么呢
导致大量的行情
会在1TH走完
大量的行情在1TH走完
然后到达了
RTH的时候
我也不停地trop
他跌不下去
但是也长不上去
因为你可以
你通过这个期权结构
你就可以想象到
在当天是什么样的
就是每到了新的一天
每盘开盘
首先风泳而致的是什么
是大量的
因为隔夜跳空
这个gap导致的
导致的那种散户也好
什么也好的报仓
这里有大量的卖盘去平藏
就会导致在现货里
会有大量的多单去买入
但是同时
就像我说的那种魔法对红
前一天的
当他
当这些人卖put平藏的时候
他买回这些put
这个时候
在微观层面
本来因为长期的下行
他的gamma是-的
每天都会处在一个-的环境里
但是他的-的
他的-的是-的
这个时候在更微观的层面
这种-的长口他会消失
做事上需要去买入现货
去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去去
这部分的深度深度虚之的put它会萎缩
它一萎缩下去
它就不需要那么多空单去对冲
所以说又开始去买鲜货
但是这个时候你要明白
对于对wix的担忧
这个时候还会有大量的静悦的wix的call和标普深度的虚之put在买入
所以又会到一部分
它补不掉这个概谱
它就会再横盘横盘横盘就无限在超
这个时候的欺权结构会是什么样的
就每天一开始
先是大量的wixcall会买入
会赌这个
因为你wixcall在涨
其实就差不多就这个说法不代表准
就差不多可以等价于标普会音跌或者下跌
然后同时大量的标普的虚之put被买入
比如说这是虚之
然后这是实之
然后还有大量的铁音
然后大量的蝴蝶
然后和大量的一些看跌价差
平值的put会在这种地方
会在这种地方
然后这种地方
然后因为有铁音会在这种地方
你可以看到这些价格集中在什么点呢
集中在虚之的部分
和平值的部分
但是中间的流动性是没有的
但是由于价格就不能集穿
每天每天每盘我就在看put我
每天都在put我上反复横跳
但是不能集穿那个墙
所以导致在宏观上它处于一个附的伽马节
但是在微观上它是正伽马
所以这就是为什么
就是每天电子盘走自大面
然后每盘开始横盘
这种状态我觉得可能还要持续到至少4月
反正蛮可怕的
挺恶心的
因为它只有在当前价格附近
和大量的虚纸
有大量的订单
但是在其他价格
它的流动性是没有的
而这些价格又去不了
然后也不能集穿put我
就无限
超不超不超不超不
你直到收盘
快到收盘莫为的时候
又会留下一地的保险
从第二天周而复始的开始
反正这就是我对于目前行情的一些思考
如果是对于期货交易来说
可能更多的要去考虑一个
摩托皮
不能去读大的方向
如果大的方向如果有的话
一般都会在eth去产生
而不会在eth去产生
这就是我的一部分理解